la gente quiere la caída del régimen
así corearon miles de sudaneses que se
oponen al reciente acuerdo firmado entre
los militares y el primer ministro de la
janda quien fue derrocado el pasado 25
de octubre
todos ellos piden un gobierno sin
militares
el acuerdo entre hamas y el general
abdelfatah burán no nos representa como
revolucionarios solo representa el
consejo militar y hampton ahora
consideramos a hampton como un traidor y
lo que hizo fue apuñalar a la revolución
muchos manifestantes se quejan de la
brutalidad de las fuerzas de seguridad
que aseguran han matado al menos 42
personas durante las manifestaciones
contra el ejército
y la muerte de mi hijo no fue por
asaltantes no identificados fue avalado
por fuerzas que estaban desplegadas en
el puente y estaban disparando gases
lacrimógenos y balas reales contra los
manifestantes que quemaban neumáticos y
cantaban durante la protesta los jóvenes
fueron atacados con balas reales y mi
hijo murió por una de esas balas
disparadas
el primer ministro de la anp doc y
decenas de funcionarios gubernamentales
fueron detenidos hace un mes cuando el
principal general del país abdel fattah
urán encabezó un golpe de estado contra
el gobierno civil interino el hecho ha
trastornado de los planes para la
transición de sudán a la democracia más
de dos años después de que un
levantamiento popular obligará a la
destitución del autócrata omar al bachir
el acuerdo firmado el domingo entre
hanbok y los militares ha fragmentado el
movimiento prodemocrático de sudán pues
muchos de ellos acusan al primer
ministro de que el documento servirá
para la continuación de un gobierno
militar